what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Iron Man as part of fall
of X and as always you will find a link
to the fall of X playlist at the end of
this video so you can get caught up on
everything but we pick up here with Iron
Man and Emma Frost on a honeymoon don't
worry it gets amazing here in a second
but for those of you guys who are
getting caught up here the long and
short of it is that as most of you know
from Fall of X the X-Men are basically
being hunted down really all mutants are
being hunted down attacked by the human
population pretty much anywhere they can
find them Emma Frost is basically
masquerading as a chick named Hazel
who's now the wife of Tony Stark which
is just one great big huge ruse but it
allows her to operate in the public eye
without anybody being the wiser as to
who she actually is but once the two of
them just kind of finish doing their
thing right like Iron Man surfing she's
like drinking my Ties on the beach he
walks back into the hotel room and she's
like are you ready to get it on which is
probably like the one thing he wanted to
hear the most from Emma Frost only to be
disappointed and find out she's just
talking about the mission so one of the
cool things here right this is the
awesome aspect of this and we covered
this in the last video they're hunting
for mysterium well specifically she
already knows where it is but Iron Man
is looking for it because he's looking
to build the mark 72 a new Iron Man suit
based off of this mysterium metal we'll
find out exactly how capable this metal
is over the course of this video and
it's going to blow your mind but using
the nil armor which is really more of
like a Espionage spy armor it can make
him invisible it's really more designed
for getting in and out of places as
opposed to like a weaponized suit of
armor using that he ends up traveling to
kcoa now the cool thing is that once he
gets there a lot of the continuity of
what we've seen so far remains intact in
the sense that in the Iron Man Comics fa
long is very much anti- mutant really
for the dumbest reason imaginable right
like his parents had powers he didn't
have powers and he's been pissed off
about it ever since but the the thing
about this is that he stole Iron Man's
company and then used Stark Tech to
build these giant Sentinels which are
still guarding the entire island of kcoa
the former home of the mutant population
on Earth and so Iron Man sneaking in
here is really just based on the fact
that the nil armor of course is far more
advanced than the traditional Sentinels
and even the Iron Man or the Stark Tech
Sentinels that Fong's using just because
Tony Stark knows exactly what technology
is being used here right I mean the guy
in effect built the whole thing and so
because of this as he sneaks in one of
the cool things that goes on here is
that Emma Frost is able to see
everything through these glasses that
she's wearing right like she sees what
Iron Man sees so they're basically
cameras and as he's making his way
through here one of the things we find
out is that orcus the organization
hunting down mutants all over the world
that they have superpowered Apes no it's
not gorilla grod but it is still kind of
cool all right so here's the Thing Once
Iron Man is kind of guided to the room
of Emma Frost which looks every bit as
cold as you would expected to it's the
least inviting space that I think I've
ever seen in my life she tells them
exactly where to go right like there's a
chest it's got these thigh high boots
that are sitting on top of it once you
crack the chest open the mysterium metal
if it hasn't been stolen will be
available right you'll see it there the
crazy thing about this is that this
gorilla immediately attacks now it's not
as though it perfectly sof Iron Man
instead the way it explains this right
it says that Fong tuned our satellites
to find a new element and an anomalous
reading on a satellite spectrometer
brought me here I didn't expect to find
you where is the White Queen Iron Man so
essentially Tony Stark and Emma Frost
are not the only ones who know about
mysterium now I would go so far as to
wager that while mysterium is being
introduced within the confines of this
story for the purpose of building an
Iron Man suit this will become a much
bigger thing later on down the line
within Marvel Comics and that it may end
up turning into some kind of like a
space race for this Mysteria metal I
don't definitively know that that's just
kind of my guess here but of course as
you would expect in traditional Iron Man
fashion he starts cracking jokes when
like the giant ape says like no Japes of
course you got to make a joke right like
no Japes for Apes like you got to say
something you can't just let that slide
but while like Iron Man is basically
getting trash
by this monkey Emma Frost is just kind
of watching through her glasses drinking
some wine and it's just kind of like I
told you this would be a disaster Tony I
told you it was a bad idea right they've
got multiple phds that's how smart this
monkey is Right multiple phds now of
course once iron man tries to lie and
say like I'm not actually Tony Stark
that kind of thing it's really more just
buying time right like creating a ruse
so on and so forth he is ultimately able
to overcome it by like blasting the
ceiling which brings the whole thing
crashing down on this ape and ultimately
kills him but following that he gets to
the chest and when he cracks it open
it's literally a line it's like a scene
out of Pulp Fiction right like yeah
we're happy opening the briefcase and
just seeing it Glow and realizing that
marcelis Wallace has his soul back so
here's the thing right once they leave
or once he starts to leave this is one
of the coolest aspects of the story it's
not a gigantic moment but it is a great
reference and this is why I love tie-in
for like major events what he does is he
says I only had boots on the ground for
a few minutes on the island but I was
left with the strangest Sensation that I
was not alone and the reality is he's
not he's being watched and in fact he's
actually being protected Charles Xavier
basically is the reason why nobody saw
him there right because the reality here
is that if these satellites that orbit
Earth and controlled by F long are being
adjusted at a frequency that's
constantly trying to find the nil armor
and then potentially even located the
exact frequency which would basically
nullify the invisibility of the suit
that while he is still technically
invisible while he's making his way
through these guys should have picked up
on it right sounds or any number of
things but the fact that Charles Xavier
was there basically he uses telepathy to
keep these guys from realizing that Iron
Man was present now that ties into the
immortal X-Men comic which we also have
in the fall of X playlist Xavier is just
like the one guy who won't Leaf kcoa
he's there the whole time and in fact
things are going sideways pretty fast
for his character I'm really interested
to see where that goes to be honest but
following that once he gets back to the
hellfire club kind of the base of
operations where he and Emma Frost and
Kingpin and this kind of anti- orcus
resistance where they're all operating
out of then of course he activates his
kind of like room right his uh Workshop
if you want to call it that which really
just looks like an SNM room if we're
being honest with ourselves and what has
happened here is that specifically he's
had his machines building a cane using
this mysterium armor now of course using
a cane it's very non-conspicuous right
like Tony Stark walking around with a
cane nobody's going to bat an eye if
he's walking around in like a giant
metal suit people are going to ask
questions you know what I mean but what
he wants to do is he wants to see how
capable this mysterium metal is and I'm
going to tell you guys right now
building an Iron Man suit out of this
metal is going to be nuts I would argue
that it Rivals true Adam man technically
it doesn't but I would argue that it
does right because the first person he
takes it to is like Carol Danvers and
he's just like break this in half and
she can't she can't break it right now
this is the chick who's almost on par
with the Incredible Hulk I say almost on
par because during Jonathan Hickman
Avengers and New Avengers in like one of
the best moments ever like she's
fighting The Incredible Hulk she just
like lunges at him and just starts like
wailing on him and then like when the
dust settles and the Smoke Clears he's
like are you finished and just like
uppercuts her into the atmosphere it's
amazing
but she's still exceedingly strong more
so than virtually anybody out there
outside of like maybe Thor especially
now that he's got the Thor force and
like the Incredible Hulk potentially one
or two other people but it is a smart
decision to take it to her she can't
break it right it's seemingly
indestructible the next thing he does is
he takes it to doctor strange and he
says use your magic on this right like
do whatever you want with this destroy
it incinerate it obliterate it whatever
it is that you can do and Doctor Strange
does exactly that and he's literally
just like okay I don't know what this is
right he was like I can't even cast a
simple levitation spell on this cane the
spell I just hit it with should have
atomized it right and so it's just one
of those things where it's like magic
does not affect this suit of armor and
so the next thing he does is he takes it
to Spider-Man and what he ends up doing
is as the two of them are talking it's
one of those really really it's it's a
hilarious moment right bear with me here
for a second it's it's hysterical but
there is a reason why he does this right
so he was like hello Spider-Man I was
hoping my Sinister signal wouldn't get
your attention and where Peter Parker
and Iron Man have a little bit of back
and forth banter he says I was hoping
you could help me with a science
experiment right Peter Parker is like
ecstatic about this because it's Iron
Man right like who wouldn't want to help
Iron Man with some kind of experiment
he's like you know everyone seems to
forget that I have a pretty robust and
impressive Science Background everyone
always ask you or Reed or blue Marvel
Adam Brasher because like one of the
smartest people in the world a lot of
people don't know that right blue Marvel
Dr Doom Valeria Richards Reed Richards
they trade the top spot for like the
smartest person in the Marvel Universe
we know that because of the Dr Doom solo
series for people who never read that
comic book but are going to tell me that
I'm wrong because I know what I'm
talking about and they don't but he says
nobody ever thinks of me as a science
hero what do I need to do and so the
response of Iron Man is just close your
eyes and I'll do the
rest Spider-Man's like okay gotcha and
Iron Man's like are they closed and
Spider-Man's like yep and then he just
cracks them in the leg with the cane
he's like what the heck man he was like
wait a minute my Spider Sense didn't see
that coming what is that and that's when
he realizes it can bypass Spider-Man's
spider sense right so anybody out there
that has either magical abilities super
strength someone like Spider-Man who
Spider Sense warns him of impending
danger this metal can bypass all of it
it is the single most powerful metal
that Iron Man has ever gotten his hands
on to use for an Iron Man suit so the
questions got to be asked once this suit
gets made which will likely be in the
next comic what's going to happen
because I'm excited to find out which we
will next month with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an
end they release it monthly what do you
want me to tell you but make sure you
guys click this link to the fall of X
playlist and I will catch you all later
peace